I think that if aliens captured humans
and and they had a zoo in the alien
planet you had to choose that I would
have my own you would get your own who
else who do you think would be next to
you they would have different kinds I
think John Cena
10 celebrities right if you had to
choose 10 celebrities because you you
would have to Showcase different types
right that's what I'm saying okay so
this is going to be a fat Korean one
from San Diego Brad Brad Williams oh for
sure from from no but I would not get
him there's other more I didn't want to
say it
um the um the guy the short guy on the
Game of Thrones I never watched Game of
Thrones but I heard it was really really
good so he but if I was an alien George
is like good if I was an alien right I
would have to dress up the exhibition
too so with Peter Dinklage what I would
do is have a fireplace and haven't put
him in a smoking jacket yeah right and
so that's how you would see him he's a
little person he's a little person okay
okay so you have Peter Dinklage his name
the 10 in the zoo right the alien he's
an actor little so okay yeah so John
Cena John Cena's exhibition would
probably be what I would have like a
bunch of like kind of dummies you know
what I mean punching thing you know like
punching you know right weights I mean
you just have like a big like like hand
in the front of the window
right that's interesting very
interesting motion very interesting like
parts of the day yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah right so an alien would have
to kind of move yes find the spot
exactly thank you so much and that's why
you're a part of the alien Zoo
exhibition thank you I'm on the board
now you're on the board yeah for sure
right thank you number three I think
either you or Danny DeVito
that's probably the rudest thing
that hurts so [__] bad just now I
have to let that [__] Danny DeVito
who's short and funny short and funny oh
my God is that the name of you would
think that Danny DeVito would be more of
the Peter dinklers between them too see
I thought you're gonna go more like
Korean celebrity or Comics maybe choose
one comic the committee is not getting
along okay okay so we agreed on John
Cena Yeah that's good yeah
that's right we'll talk about me later
right so that's the musicians who we
would have that hot chick we would have
to have the Prototype like a Pam
Anderson oh yeah oh we're talking people
who aren't even alive like yet well
she's alive
I say we're opening it up to like can we
open it up uh let me see can we tell
people Bob yeah oh no it's no no maybe
aliens if we have the technology to re
yeah then Michael Jackson does Michael
Jackson for sure you know who that is
yeah
yes I do I I actually I really do I
actually watched Jackson Five the movie
The Seven Hour long movie yeah twice why
twice
the first time no I I tried to learn the
songs what is the Jackson 5 my favorite
Christmas album is The Jackson 5
Christmas album in the Michael Jackson
exhibition what would you put in there
well you put a monkey in there he loves
those yeah does he yeah he had his own
monkey he did yeah it was a giraffe what
was his monkey to his monkey was a
Famous Dave let me try to guess that it
was um
Sparkle not Sparkle uh
is it yeah yeah his monkey was called
it was a chimp I forgot damn it but he
had a famous what's it called bubbles
bubbles bubbles
we put a monkey in there okay yeah and
then we probably is this is this an
interactive one where your kids can walk
through no
alien kids yeah yeah all right I mean we
could have a little ride it's just two
two we're feeding and just moons walk
just all the way right and here's what
we'll do too we put mannequins in there
right but mannequins from like uh Gap
Kids hmm
yeah well I mean you could have
different different outfits yeah yeah
you could have different outfit although
you know he would ruin those [__]
mannequins I think
the aliens are clinging up one day it's
like why are there so many holes and
there's a hand in the mannequins
this one's ruined
he's biting the thighs
[Laughter]
okay so dude let's go to a different
exhibitions let's do three women three
women in one exhibition that's great
yeah like the most different looking
type of Whoopi Goldberg oh duh no no yes
from scary movies I was gonna say like
excuse me
what are you saying what is it I love
this guy it's ghost ghost okay see
there's a few scary movie with ghosts no
did you see ghosts no no
he doesn't know that's right I love this
guy so just put Whoopi in it we'll trust
me okay yeah he's an older
African-American lady black lady yes
yeah so we put wolf in there what about
one of the freaking what about what
about one of the um
Charlie's Angels you know what I'm
saying like which one though there's uh
the one that the original or the new one
or the the ridge yeah that's what I'm
saying like a blonde like on like a
buxom blonde but it's got to be somebody
if because we're aliens right and we're
on earth now capturing right oh we're
the we're the aliens
I thought we were humans putting okay
got you okay so you're saying that
aliens hired us yeah I thought we were
subcontracted out oh wow what the
military does yeah I see okay yeah so no
kidding my thinking no no no you're
right I think we should be human yes
yeah so we're under a little pressure
exactly represent us yeah no this
Museum's opening end of September end of
September also like if we're on crunch
time and if we don't get this [__] right
they put us in the zoo oh yeah all right
committee is under pressure I want to
take out walkway let's put it in grinder
well I was thinking instead of putting
different types like maybe from
different countries instead nah
America we're doing nah nah you know I
got one Kevin Spacey
and what is his thing he just likes to
[__] young boys that's crazy
in there oh that's right you're right
it's one of the same Maybe
yeah yeah and just as a guy that's a
part of the board I just want to throw
out a suggestion what do you throw it
out man can we do a little exhibit can
we just have Hitler's mustache
if we can find it yeah yeah okay thank
you